so we're going to start off by talking
about scopes and closures since you
really need to fully understand those
aspects of functions and variable access
before we can move on to more advanced
topics of object-oriented programming
then we'll discuss the parameter this
and prototype delegation which are the
two main language features allowing for
object-oriented JavaScript finally we'll
cover a number of different ways that
you can write JavaScript classes and
subclasses by the end of this you'll
have a strong understanding of
JavaScript object-oriented features and
how the code you write impacts the
interpreters in-memory model as your
code is executing